let's on that happy note look at the
washington football team
bigger picture you and i both like what
they've done this year via free agency
in the draft they are not the favorites
via our friends at points bet to win the
division the cowboys still are we've
made the point recently there's now
three games that vary and because they
won the division the washington football
team has a tough draw for those three
games they get the bills they get the
packers they get the seahawks whereas
the other teams in the division have
lesser opponents from those same
divisions
quarterback hey look ryan fitzpatrick
great story been around forever went to
harvard if you haven't heard
fits magic it's great but you know every
time he does another one of those
special things like throwing a a a pass
that sets up a field goal to win a game
while his head's being twisted off of
his body
we forget about the fact that he has
some moments that cause you to say this
guy went to harvard yeah so you got to
be ready for that if you're a fan of the
wft this year there's going to be plenty
of wtf with ryan fitzpatrick yes you
have to be aware of that there is a
gunslinger aspect of ryan fitzpatrick
there's no doubt i'll say this in
defending that a little bit it has been
wilted away the last few years i will
say that
you know i do think it's been more fits
magic than fits tragic you know i do
think he's actually played a a you know
a smarter brand of football you know
when he was in miami and even towards
even towards his end you know at the
jets and things like that so hey the
numbers here they kind of show you he's
being a little smarter with the football
but the big thing is mike to like what
you said
you know they've done a good job this
team he doesn't need to be you know
superman here they got a lot of good
players and he's got good receivers and
a pretty good offensive line and
everything like that to where if he's
smart with that defense he does he
should never hit fitz tragic ville this
year it should be smart and be
conservative to a degree because of the
team he's got around him
i just almost feel like with him when he
authors these magical moments he
develops a level of confidence that
crosses over into hubris that causes him
to do dumb things yeah that's human
nature i'm not being critical i'm just
trying to understand how this works you
make some great plays so you suddenly
think you can make great plays all the
time my very limited experience on a
golf course taught me that hey that's a
good shot all right let's let's let's go
hit it even harder this time
plunk right into the water and i think
that that that can affect a guy when you
think you're you're firing on all
cylinders and you think you're in the
zone you push it a little too far and
you push yourself right out of the zone
yes it's it's a a fine line he has
struggled to to meet and and do that
with he has definitely had
moments of his career where
you go dude
what the hell are you doing your arm is
not brett favre you can't fit that ball
in there you know what why are you
throwing that why are you making that
decision no doubt about it but like i
said i do think it's been reigned in and
you know he's found the fine line of
being aggressive and taking advantage of
when there's aggressive explosive plays
there to be had and kind of dialing it
back and not taking as many chances
hopefully that can continue in
washington ron rivera i saw made a quote
last week though you know we got all
this talent on offense so the
quarterback doesn't have to feel like he
has to do too much i felt like he was
speaking directly to ryan fitzpatrick
with that like
don't be johnny gunslinger we got
awesome receivers pretty good running
backs a good tight end we don't need you
forcing a ball into quadruple coverage
you know down the middle of the football
field
that comment actually was from yesterday
was it yesterday for ourselves
i think it was that's the next sound
that we're gonna hear from washington
coach ron rivera
you know it's interesting because
the styles are similar
but the players are different obviously
um you know one of the positions we
relied on so heavily was quarterback in
carolina
um
in terms of of of our entire offense
here we don't necessarily have to rely
on the quarterback because we've got you
know we we do have a lot of good weapons
uh around our qb position so
um this is a little bit different for it
for me as i study it and look at it and
watch our guys um
but it's good to see the type of
personnel we have you know i thought we
improved and we improved at receiver we
improved it
tied in we've improved it running back
you know again one of the goals that you
you know you want to do when you talk
about your offense every year you want
to make sure you can protect your
quarterback and you have playmakers
around them and and i feel this year is
a different group of guys but i feel
we're in better position than we were
last year
this is the natural transition for a
head coach who had nine years of
superman and now he's got jimmy olsen
back there playing quarterback you gotta
make it work with what you have and
until you stumble into another cam
newton in his prime or before his prime
as a first overall pick you you're not
gonna have the quarterback be the guy
that you lean on but you know what there
was something revealing in that comment
yes say it and i think this is one of
one of the reasons why cam newton was
injured all the time exactly
we've got the he's he here's he just is
our guy we're gonna we're gonna ride him
right until he falls apart and you know
what he's gonna keep falling apart if
you do that and we don't have that we he
he admitted the talent wasn't that great
around him so they had to ride him hard
they had to do things everything based
around him you know and again that's
yeah it hurt cam newton and maybe his
pantheon of how he's looked at as an
elite quarterback or those type of
things but yeah i thought that was a
telling you know a telling comment by
ron rivera basically admitting that
there wasn't a ton of talent around cam
newton on the offensive side of the ball
and they had to ride him and his talents
let's throw them all in the same bucket
yeah running backs receivers in tight
ends
where do they rank relative to the teams
they're competing with
to try to win the nfc east for the
second straight year well
man you know i think you can look at it
and just you know it's it's pretty good
because of course we know all those
teams in the nfcs have improved kind of
their wide receiver position dallas not
but they didn't need to
but i you know and my heart of hearts
here
wow this is a tough one i mean we know
dallas has the best receivers and a
pretty damn good running back so they're
going to be towards the top of that
conversation the giants have the
potential to be you know but i think
it's potential it's like evan ingram's
got to be better saquon can be healthy
you know can darius slayton still be
good and how good is kenny galladay
going to be i think washington's sneaky
towards the top here i really do you
know me i'm very bullish on washington
you know the fact that it's mccoran
curtis samuel i thought adam humphries
is a nice signing they got diami brown
who i think is terry mclaurin 2.0 can
fly so i think it's it's towards the top
half of football certainly with the
potential to be better than that which
is some young kind of unproven commodity
still showing their way
yeah i'm surprised that you would put
them ahead of the cowboys though no i
don't know if i would i think it's i
might give the cowboys one and them
right on their heels at two i think
that's the way i'd probably look at it
and i think the difference between the
two teams is the defense the cowboys
clearly a work in progress at best the
washington defense sneaky great has the
potential chris to be among the best
in the league this year you think i do i
mean i i think you and i we were amazed
at what they did last year you know also
i think another year in the system where
jack del rio can maybe you know be a
little bit more creative and maybe
certain things and change it up they
were pretty basic you know they didn't
even have to trick it up last year but
the defense got better with a first
first-round linebacker and davis out of
kentucky who can fly around the field
that was a huge need for their football
team they needed to improve a corner
when you know they went out and got
william jackson in my opinion one of the
best free agent corners out there landon
collins will be back healthy and and
playing this year who got hurt last year
so they made that defense better in my
opinion and they had a few injuries on
the defensive line last year too that
hurt their depth a little bit so i look
at washington's defense and go watch out
like there's no doubt they're gonna be
top five in football and yeah they have
the potential to be like special special
number one good uh at least from you
know what we saw last year and the guys
on this roster
well what do you think do you think
they're going to be dominant like kick
kick butt or do they fall in the trap
and take a step back or something like
that on the defensive side of the ball
schedule's not easy yeah schedule's not
easy they play all the teams
uh from the
afc west and all the teams from the nfc
south yeah
um and you know they've got those final
five games
against division rivals
it's going gonna come down to that i
think
it was howard katz or mike north that
addressed that not that long ago the
idea that
that hey we know this division is going
to be tight and that's one of the
reasons why they clustered all those
washington games against cowboys and
eagles and giants to end the season
because look you could have two or three
wins going into those last five games
and still be in contention to run the
table and win the division yes no no
doubt about it i mean it's all going to
be at play there and i think none of us
look at any of the teams in the nfcs and
just think oh juggernaut this team's
gonna run away with the division so yeah
i would agree with those thoughts but
you're right it is a tough schedule it
really is it's not gonna be easy out of
the gates and that's where
fitzpatrick is gonna have to be smart
and the defense is gonna have to be
special but i mean i would expect chase
young to take a step and then the right
direction you know montez sweat he had
more sacks than chase young last year he
was really damn good he didn't get a lot
of credit because of chase young we
didn't talk about him but man they're
stacked on that side of the ball
washington is one of those teams where i
look at like i know they were in the
playoffs last year
but
they have the potential to kind of
at least in my opinion with what they
look like where if they peak i'd go
they could make a run in the nfc
playoffs i think there's enough talent
and and real difference makers on their
roster to do that type of thing
i don't think the buccaneers want to see
him again i would buccaneers got
everything they can handle washington on
that that saturday night game to start
the postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports